today's topic i love anime a lot of
people know this i do anime live streams
and stuff like that
and one person coming up is like man
japanese people are so obsessed with
white books
that they make all their anime
characters look white
now this is a very common idea people
believe for a long time
that when japanese people are drawing
these characters they're all made to
look like caucasian folks
i thought that too there's a really
important video i want you guys to watch
hey guys
it's ita so if anime characters are
white is an
age old question but have you actually
asked japanese people about it
check this out
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey
[Music]
foreign
what
[Music]
um
personally i hadn't even thought about
anime characters being
white until somebody pointed out because
anime characters have always
looked japanese to me and not even
generic east asian
they looked specifically japanese
[Music]
you just know there's a russian watching
this with some vodka in his hand like
we are smart
that was very smart no
why do i want to play this video because
i think
i think the west dominates online media
a lot
and they impose their standards and
their issues on everyone else
yeah meaning the way that they feel
about a certain topic and the problems
that they have they feel like everyone
else must be dealing with in the same
way
in japan with their context and their
history right they look at these
characters and they see themselves or
they see other japanese people
when they look at it when we look at it
we see a symbol of
white supremacy also but it's not but it
doesn't make it true and considering
that they invented it right
that they make this stuff i do think
there's a bit of
arrogance in the sense that we think
everything revolves around us and we
impose our ideas
on people over things that they
themselves made right
and so when you sit there you're like
well this is what it means to you
how would you know you're not living
their context you don't understand what
they're going through
right and i think we have to be careful
not to go into the world thinking the
concepts that we understand everyone's
going to understand in the same way
and that this was very humbling for me
because i believed that my whole life
i'd heard it so i'm like
yeah you know white people everyone
wants to be colorism band i got
but it's not necessarily the case for
everyone else when i was ready to
dispute it i was like nah man that
definitely was going on
because of this and that and that the
jawbone and
the the way they do surgery and stuff
like that
but they have a whole different way of
thinking that
they they really do and they see
themselves in there
and when they draw white people it's
very different i've seen that in mangas
i've seen that in
uh in uh it's different it's not like
the main characters
it's when it's white people you can tell
you could tell you can tell there is a
difference there is actually a
difference well they could tell they
when they saw that they immediately
thought like oh he must be somewhere
else
yeah you just have to you have to look
at
you have to watch a lot of mangas and a
lot of things to to to know that not
only that but you have to ask questions
yeah you have to
to as a proper question so that was that
video was very interesting
and very eye-opening into other people's
yeah um reality right so you might be
looking
why aren't the eyes you know more
squinty or whatever because when you're
drawing character you want them to be
able to express themselves
and if you were drawing a character eyes
are often how a lot of anime characters
express surprise all the features are
exaggerated so that's why they do that
not only that
their eyes are actually
slightly like some characters but but i
mean
the way white people has been depicting
depicting asian people has been a
caricature
yeah so it's been no eyes at all where
you could clearly see their eyes right
you know what i'm saying
so there's that too the idea that we had
it we've been fed
all these times it's just easier like
you'll see certain characters who got
like a very simple face and you got
these eyes
that's why people why they got blonde
hair why do they got green hair why do
they got purple hair nobody looks like
that
but they use it to differentiate the
characters because having to draw
everyone with specific type of faces
takes
too much time it's too expensive so how
do you differentiate between
person a and poison b well you change
their hair color you change their eye
color you do whatever
right so it's important for me for me
was really humbling they learned from
dragon ball z
i remember when i was in elementary
school and i saw first person reading
some dragon ball z
no he had a dragon ball z shirt right
and it was
all the different type of people on
there and i was like
uh why is all the same dude
uh it's not this is a song goku this is
go on this is this
this is trunks it's like nah it's the
same dude
but that's yamcha no that's the same
dude with longer hair
but yeah dragon ball z did trigger
because like you know
they've got all these different
characters green characters and the one
black guy that they got
he's a black face yeah and his little mr
popo
literally police yeah i'm like bruh you
i get it you don't like [ __ ] but you
didn't have to go that far they they
went there yo
but anyways um that was that was fun
it went there that was yeah but yeah
this is all that i want to bring so
you know if you come from the west and
you're traveling be open to the fact
that they might view certain concepts
completely different than you
whether it be like for example consent
or asia can send stuff like that the way
it looks in america it's not the way it
looks in france it's not the way it
looks in parts africa it's not the way
it looks in japan
and you can't look at it as like
predatory inherently you're coming with
your own different context
all right people can't understand why
you guys need guns in america
that's your context to everyone else you
look crazy doesn't mean that they're
necessarily right
okay so that's why i mean when i said we
gotta take sometimes a couple steps back
and not impose our views
our cultural experience on everyone
else's culture
that's how you call that cultural
relativism i think it's the
term and you know for example my country
in ethiopia
you know like here when i'm in the west
everyone eats with you know utensils all
that stuff in my country
oftentimes we eat with our hands it's
like how we eat our main dishes
people might look like that that's
barbaric it's a different cultural
experience for us it's
grounding it feels much better me
personally eating between both i prefer
that
but for a lot of people who see for the
first time they go ill they don't
understand it
here we got sofas and couches over there
it's just
right that's all over the floor it's a
different way of living
it's different stuff so um yeah
honestly i really like this video i like
this video because it was
it was eye-opening yeah it humbles you
it reminds you not the center of the
universe neither are your people yep
you know and that's important sit down
be humble why
why is this skin pale or whatever it's
easier to draw
and they've got a lot harder to draw
other characters they got pale skin
yep yeah now it doesn't mean that
there's some form of white washing in
certain areas and
but i think a lot of what people point
to isn't accurate
so we just have to have the discussion a
bit more of a nuance
you have to calm down and learn to
listen
calm down learn to listen and ask
questions
yeah yeah um that's it
one last thing i probably touch on the
the downside of
doing what you guys are doing is you end
up erasing other people's culture
you ascribe a completely different
cultural reason for why they're doing it
when they may have a whole
history of reasons why they're at that
point but you erase that you say no it's
white surprise
well they have a completely different
experience so
what you do in doing this is you
minimize other people's cultures that's
what you do
you make everything about one thing when
there's all sorts of like geographical
historical
economical reasons why they make the
choices that they make
and um it's important not to do that to
others so
that's so i think pretty much the gist
of it pretty much yeah
all right listen we want to hear what
you guys think so leave comments below
do you guys agree
or disagree go on open the floor so we
want to hear your thoughts
[Music]
foreign